[Musique]
les êtres humains ont un désir incommensurable
de découvrir mais à chaque nouvelle découverte
[Musique]
il y a des conséquences Ben Grimm est un
adolescent américain typique
c'est le meilleur ami de Reed Richards il fera
tout pour le protéger ne laissez aucun de
ces laboratoires  les codes pourraient être n'importe quelle merde salut
ils sont dans une sorte d'horrible
accident il devient si éloigné de
la forme humaine qu'il a littéralement fait des rochers
[Musique]
Sue Storm a été adoptée par le dr.  tempête et
Johnny est son frère elle est très
intelligente après le gros accident elle
peut devenir invisible ou utiliser un champ de force
même si j'ai demandé si je suis toujours
très humain
[Musique]
Johnny est un accro à l'adrénaline il aime
marcher  jusqu'à la ligne il marcherait
sur une ligne si tu avais un accident nous
devons faire face à la vie après cet
événement traumatisant toutes ces capacités viennent
d'une autre dimension Johnny
regarde c'est une grande opportunité d'enfin
trouver son but et j'ai vraiment aimé
à propos de Reed Richards était son hyper
intelligence il veut utiliser toutes ses
connaissances pour pouvoir faire quelque chose
que personne n'a fait avant cet
accident c'est très traumatisant toutes ces
capacités viennent d'une autre dimension
ayant une élasticité complète c'est beaucoup de
puissance vous pouvez travailler ensemble  vous pouvez
modifier l'historique des cours que
vous
[Musique]